michel d'ailleurs tout à l'heure à la
nouvelle de leur modem ça ouais on sait
la steppe supérieur il est bon mathieu
didion sarlat ouais c'est vrai
vous pouvez y aller à part tout bon soit
la valeur celui-ci alesi savez tablette
qui n'est là ce petit quoi allait même
se montrer c'est que je vais là d'accord
m et lui là c'est michel à vue ils sont
très bien foutu tes chroniques
oui oui c'est mieux ça pauvre c pour
attraper le corps du patron
[Applaudissements]
mais non c'est moi je suis ventriloque
alésien savez que c'est bien et c'est
cyril hanouna
l'art est sur la table non mais je suis
fou de ce chien alors attention
olalala c'est tout à fait extraordinaire
que j'ai dans ma vie de trois mois
seulement 206 qui vient de roumanie mon
pays d'origine pour ça que c'est très
émouvant j'ai et puis voilà je suis
maintenant foot ce chien je dors dans le
panier je mange des croquants
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
ouais y regarde bien son regard c'est
pas un chien non c'est qui c'est un être
humain et elle sait qu'elle a un bon
profil
michel je croyais qu'il aime bien tu
vois regardez un c'est pas un chien
c'est ta femme
dans ce métier il ya trois catégories de
gens et censure la troisième génération
qui a su comme beaucoup de talent et
qu'on aurait préféré ne pas connaître
parce que humainement ils sont pas au
niveau de leurs talents gérard connaît
comme moi il ya c'est donc il ya ceux
qui n'ont aucun talent et qui sont
imbuvables n'en parle même pas et puis
un cercle très fermé des gens qui ont
beaucoup de talent et qui sont des gens
biens sans les concevoir dès demain mais
quand vous vous feriez un vivement
dimanche avec nabila et que je la
connais pas qui c'est nabil sommes
passés on va on va il est telle que tu
veux qu'il dit allô allô
mais je n'ai jamais rencontré j'ai vu
qu'une seule fois les rallys mais quel
est le problème parce qu'elle est venu
avec sa famille
oui mais ils ont dû camper sur le
plateau du grand journal as et ça nous
va scorer c'est ta faute tout ça mais
pourquoi mais parce que ton émission a
trop de succès alors le grand journal
idée rouille
[Applaudissements]
prolin démission a tellement de succès
que le grand journal il ramena avec
memish genre à des problèmes c'est le
même groupe
je sais que ces mêmes responsables je
sème la merde benjamin castaldi nikos
aliagas benjamin que vous avez longtemps
on va de 2 aboiements c'est nikos
aliagas
[Musique]